i'm going to uh
maybe offend some people with my next
comment we don't have a lot of speakers
here so that's good
i'm not a big believer
in making quantitative decisions and
that applies to social media campaigns
i'm not the guy who's going to look at
all the market research
and say here's what people are talking
about
so here's what we're going to tweet
about
the problem with making quantitative
only decisions
is that there's no passion in it there's
no emotion to it
you don't feel excited by it
it's like people who start a business
just trying to make money if you are
trying to start a business just trying
to make money you're never gonna make it
money is important i'm not saying you
start a business or in your company now
you ignore the quantitative stuff but
it's not the reason to do something
one of my favorite entrepreneurs is
steve jobs
you guys like steve jobs
no come on guys steve jobs
all right good hands up
i love steve jobs okay now
steve jobs the story this guy was a
multi-millionaire in his early 20s
multi-millionaire in his early twenties
he had enough money to live the rest of
his life and happiness
and yet he worked until the day he died
making amazing products
for apple why did he do it it wasn't for
the money
and people told him he was crazy people
told him at the beginning of apple
nobody needs a personal computer what
are you stupid nobody needs a personal
computer
when he launched the ipad when he
launched the ipod people thought he was
crazy people thought this will never
this will never sell because there's no
data to prove it
there's no quantitative data why did he
do it
he did it because he felt like this was
needed he did it to do it
that's why he did he did it because it
was important because he wanted to
change the world
and for steve jobs the number one
criteria was never the money it was
never the quantitative stuff
and yet
he built apple to become the number one
most valuable company in the world by
market cap
that's the power when you inject your
own passion
into your business so i'm not saying
completely ignore the quantitative stuff
but you don't make decisions in this
context social media campaigns only on a
quantitative stuff
you have to get excited and feel it in
your heart of every single post that
you're putting on your social media
campaign
and you'll post stuff on there
even ignoring the quantitative stuff
because it's the right thing to do
and if you do that then you'll gain a
loyal following
and people will can't wait to see your
next tweet
and then they're gonna buy from you and
tell everybody about you
that's my view